ça ça fait de la peine d'avoir fait de
la peine à des des gens ouais vraiment
ça c'est important tu le dis comment va
ta maman elle est contente que ça se
calme un peu tout ça pour toi elle est
contente parce qu'elle avait très peur
pour toi ouais elle a toujours peur elle
a toujours peur
est-ce que vous avez peur pour vous un
peu vous avez peur un peu oui mais oui
oui tu t'es fait suivre ou pas depuis
finalement non
j'ai voulu aller en clinique pour me
faire interner ou que j'ai entendu dire
et finalement je n'ai pas été parce que
apparemment j'avais pas de j'ai pas eu
de diagnostic en fait pour me définir
comme tu avais envie de te faire
interner pour je pensais que je pensais
que j'étais malade en fait je pensais
que j'étais fou je pensais que ça c'est
important
et finalement personne n'a voulu
m'attarder donc
je suis resté chez moi j'ai réfléchi sur
moi-même et maintenant j'ai un psy aussi
qui mais ouais quand j'ai voulu vraiment
être aidé et être internet simplement je
n'ai pas été